Eddie Olczyk NBC Sports NHL and
horse-racing analyst and Eddie joins us
Game five coming up tonight the Cup will
be in the house Eddie good morning how
are you I'm doing well dan nice to be
with you hope you're well who would be
the LeBron James of the NHL with a man
maybe it's you know Sid the kid but
where you get all this criticism that
goes along with the greatness the
Ovechkin doesn't tie into that category
does he what who's that I'm sorry
Ovechkin doesn't yeah I think he's I
think he's always been an easy target
for people Dan that being Ovechkin a
because he's not from North America and
B I think early in his career he was
thinking about one thing and that was
the offensive side of the puck but over
the course of the last five plus years I
mean he has become a much better two-way
player he's always had the same reaction
that's the one thing I love about him
most is that you don't know if he scores
or one of his teammates scores he has
the same reaction and you can't say that
about a lot of athletes in general so
I'm just been super impressed the way
that he is matured and understood how to
play and this had a couple of great
years but haven't been able to get it
done but I would say that Sidney Crosby
is easily the guy that I would compare
to when it comes to you know the NBA and
a guy like LeBron James when it comes to
scrutinizing you know every single thing
and why didn't he do this and whitey to
do that and hey you know what when
you're the best you know the critics are
going to be after you day in and day out
what's that feeling like when you hear
the cup is in the house well it meant a
lot when I was a player in New York in
94 when we knew it was in the building
for a game five at Madison Square Garden
in 1994 against the Vancouver Canucks
and you know unfortunately for us so we
got off to a rough start in Game five
came back tied it up and next thing you
know Vancouver wins the game then we got
a flick you know felt like across the
world to Vancouver for Game six and we
played our worst game of the year and I
think the one thing that helped us in 94
Dan was we had an extra day in between
for travel so we had two extra days
to kind of get ourselves back on track
for a game seven back at the garden so
when they get when the cup is in the
building is a player it's hard not to
and again being on the side that had a
chance to win it it is a feeling like no
other because you're so close you can
taste it you can feel it you want to
touch it you want to grab it but you
know you got a long ways to go even
though it's a 60 minute or 60 plus
minute hockey game as a broadcaster it
always gets I always get chills when I
see them shining it up and getting ready
to be presented in the building so it's
to me it's it's the greatest trophy in
all of professional sports and you know
it's it's just just a feeling you can't
describe as far as a player but as a
broadcaster still get still gets very
emotional when you have the Stanley Cup
in the building what would be a bigger
surprise a bigger upset the Capitals
losing or justify losing hmm are you
saying tonight or the theory this series
oh you know I might have to run down to
the race and sports book and see if I
can get that way before the game that
night then we are in Las Vegas and
everything everything seems to be legal
so I would say probably the bigger
surprise for me would be and this is
hard for me to say would probably be the
Capitals losing this series and
justifying my Saturday but it's close
yeah very very close I would say it's
probably by a I was gonna say a nose but
I'll say a horse's back and how's that
alright how can I make money this
weekend on the Belmont well I think you
got to get a little creative because I
don't think anybody's beating justifying
Saturday then I just think that the mile
and a half race and as far as my
experience of handicapping and playing
the horses for a long long time is that
you know these distance races these mile
and half races really become a half mile
journey the first mile is to kind of
gallop along and get position and
justify will do just that with Mike
Smith Mike Smith is this pilot braking
from post position one and then last
half-mile is where history will be made
I don't think that there's anybody that
can run with them I think the extra week
extra week will do Bob Baffert and
justify a world of good so to me you got
a look at the exotics you got a look at
the exact is you got a look at the
trifectas and so I'm looking at you know
justify the one horse and hofburg the
four horse and I'm gonna play all kinds
of gimmick with the one winning and the
four finishing second and third and
hopefully you get a long shot to finish
in third or second and split hofburg and
justify and but I think there is there
is going to be value and look I just
talking to a lot of people dance since
the Preakness I think a lot of people
have jumping off have jumped off the
bandwagon of justify I think they feel
that he's vulnerable
wow they feel like maybe if that last
race you know bravado was gonna go by on
the horse that finished second at the
Preakness I'm not one of them I think
Mike Smith knew exactly what he was
doing the last 70 yards when he put good
magic away so for me you might you might
look at what's wrong what's wrong with
making you know 90 cents on a dollar I
mean there's really nothing wrong with
that people try to do that every day in
the real world and down in Wall Street
so for me if you can get three to five
or four to five unjustified I think that
might be a that might be a heck of a
wager I saw this tweet by Darrin Ravel
from ESPN the amount of money that goes
uncashed when it comes to betting on
like if justify wins the Triple Crown
there's going to be probably a couple
hundred thousand dollars that goes
uncashed because they want to keep their
ticket yeah has anybody ever done a
story on just how much money has you
know just left there and and how long do
I have before I that I can cash in that
ticket what's the time frame yeah it's
one year usually at most at most
racetracks and most states for cashing
tickets so you got you know you got one
year to be able to to do that as far as
a horse racing part of it and look I
mean there there are lots of lots of
stories where people you know not just
you know they don't cash it on purpose
but there are a lot of people that may
ask for a certain wager when they go to
the window and they get another one and
they think that okay then I lost and
then they just like mean the
exact number I couldn't tell you but I
mean there are millions and millions of
dollars every year of uncashed
horse-racing wagers and so then people
you know that that don't realize or
don't understand the type of bet that
they made or they ask for something
specific and they thought it was
different but as far as the people just
wanted to have you know have that
hundred-dollar win bet unjustified that
you know the day wins the Triple Crown
or American Pharoah a couple of years
ago you're right I mean I could easily
see that in you know in that three four
hundred thousand dollar range for sure
without question Eddy have fun tonight
we'll be watching tell doc we said hello
and Pierre will talk to you soon okay
thanks and have a great day
Eddy old Chuck NBC Sports NHL and also
horse-racing analyst for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]